zanzibar zanzibar caribou zanzibar
one of the beautiful island in africa
which is surrounded by indian ocean
zanzibar the best place to be
then
my name is mamo juma i started scuba
diving in 1980s
i love the ocean
it's so wonderful when i scuba dive i
feel great
i remember when i was doing my first
dive
there is so many beautiful things
a world of swan
i remember in every dive we could see
like 40-50 titles
in the same dive site it was divine but
as the days goes on i don't see many
titles like
the way i used to see them
those years back
that's the time when i decided it would
be a good idea to participate in
conservation of turtles
jumbo people my name is layman nahoda i
was born in nungwi which is located on
northern tip of zanzibar in tanzania
we are a narani marine tata conservation
project
this activity started since 1993 by the
local people from nunu village the main
mission which is for educational
purposes than conserving the island
tati's populations
project founder his name is mr mataka
who is known as baba casa father of the
sea tattoos
the local people they used to haunted to
see tata for their own purposes the meat
and the shell we had a lot of purchase
for the tata egg
my grandpa from the village was the main
fisherman from this village
they used to kill a lot of houses so
people from norway water preservation
project now we turn a look of touches in
order bring the number of touches as
used to before
we go out to the village
we talk to the village fisherman
we talk to the village school children
about conservation if we don't stop now
to eat turtles meat
eggs
selling their shells then our children
and grandchildren will not be able to
see them
one of these there which i'll
never forget about
about six months ago there was this
fisherman who brought the injury tattoo
was got stuck in the fishing nets
when this fishermen brought it here that
tartis he was looks completely tired
very tired weak and stayed in the neck
for more than two days
captain duana this is the name of the
tartan means captain hook during the
time when he was here i was looking
after him feeding him
so
today is going to be a day
of releasing
so i will
definitely miss you so what i would like
to say to you captain dwana
oh we're gonna take you gently and
release you back to dc
today is your freedom day woohoo captain
doana is to you
free wild
this creator they're here for us who
like to keep them forever like fighting
to make sure this creature they don't
disappear
you